it says find the and then it this is a
whole bunch of things to say right
so the center of motion this is the very
first thing we wrote down right we just
sort of highlighted it here the center
of motion is and please note this by the
way it's a value of X it's a
displacement right so I think you should
say that the center is not just a number
the center is it's a thing about the
displacement right so I'm gonna say it's
x equals 2 that's the center right it's
a statement about a particular values
not just a number that's flying around
okay if they asked us to describe it in
words I guess we would say it's 2
centimeters to the seen out near be
careful because they don't say up-down
left-right back and forth so I'm I can't
describe it as to the right of the
origin or above the origin so I'm just
going to leave it at that ok because
they haven't defined directions for me
that was the center all the other things
I'm after amplitude very good where do
we read that from that's the that's the
coefficient of the trig function right
which was a which in our case was just
one it's one they then asked us for the
range
okay now this one you need to think a
little bit so we know that if I didn't
have this 2 here it would just be waving
up and down around the origin right it
would go up to 1 and it would go down to
negative 1 but I don't have that I'm
sorry I just messed that up I've added 2
right so what's that done it's no longer
between negative 1 and 1 is it it's now
up to it's moved up by 2 units it's gone
from negative 1 to 1 and 1 to 3 so that
is my range but just be careful range in
this case it's not to do with wise
because there's no wise at all range is
actually to do with X's okay look at my
inequalities why are there are
boundaries included on this think about
it I've got boundaries included 1 2 3
why is that
hmm what is this thing doing this is
simple harmonic motion it's oscillating
up and down or back and forth or
whatever it is and it actually gets to
those we actually have a name for this I
don't know if we've talked about this
yet but um you know how this is the
center of motion right these guys here
are called your extremes of motion
because they are the furthest that you
get away from the center I suppose you
could call them extremities as well but
this is a more common thing to call them
so those are the extremes of motion and
you actually get to them right so that's
why I include the boundaries do they ask
us for anything else the period okay
where do we get period from we actually
looked at this in the previous example
question nine right it's going to be
three PI on n which in this case is four
so that'll be two pi on four which is PI
on two seconds Vica okay right so we've
got all together and then they say
lastly what is the maximum speed of the
particle when does it occur so I'm just
gonna make a bit of a arm I'm gonna
here's my bets a little bit is the last
part of the question do I need a graph
for this I've said before that the graph
is enormously useful in a variety of
contexts however if this is the only
thing they're asking you and they're not
asking any tricky questions they're like
how many times does it get then all I
kind of thing I reckon we could get
there just by the equations how am I
going to start talking about speed I
have no equations on the board right now
talking about feet so what I do like a
differentiating into the velocity
function now just a quick note we've
learnt about V for velocity right and
we've also learned that you can write X
dot just a personal thing I never ever
ever ever ever write x dot unless they
tell me to here's the reason why in a
hurry in an exam with a biro not a
whiteboard marker that looks a whole lot
like X and you don't want to be the
person who miss reads their own writing
and like Oh what equation was that I
mean I differentiate it again because I
forgot what I was doing I would prefer
to write something that's super clear I
know exactly what it is and I can't
mistake it for anything else so I tend
to write velocity like that because even
me like I in a hurry I write my visa a
lot like ours which are a lot like
you know other numbers which you
wouldn't believe how do people miss read
their own writing that I'm never going
to mistake for anything else yeah okay
yeah yeah look oh I mean quadratic
theory now hooray that's a bad idea so
I'm gonna make that velocity by
differentiating just like you told me
have a look here I've actually got two
equations for displacement which do you
think is a nicer one to differentiate
probably the second one right because
there's no cos squared in there I'm
still gonna have to use chain rule but
it won't be nearly so bad okay what
happens to this two when you
differentiate the two the two doesn't
make any difference right
what about cosine what does it usually
differentiate to cause goes to negative
sine so tricky here right and there's
already a negative there okay which
means that I'm gonna get positive for
sine cos is going to sign for T the
period hasn't changed yeah you okay with
that so what's the what is the maximum
speed then the maximum speed will be for
how am I going to work out when this
occurs when is it first occur I'm gonna
start back into here right for sine for
T equals four
this is an exact value we should not
pretty well what's the first value
figure out what sine does in radians PI
on two very good
we should be able to call that shape up
in our mind right and know that I'm
going to get that's one up here right so
PI on to is that value there okay so for
T equals PI on to right that's just for
regular sign but before T I'm not after
40 I'm after T so that's going to be PI
on eight hmm
is there anything else we need to say no
I'm pretty happy with that
okay so let me just rewind for a second
other centers of motion okay
increasingly now because you now know
what they look like right you have to be
ready for other centers of motion for
them to not just be oh it's just a sine
or a cosine there
something or subtract something or just
put it somewhere else based on the
equations that they give you okay so
watch out for it
and then read off all your information
based on what the graph tells you okay
in some cases as you can see I'm
obsessed with graphs but you don't
always need one
however in 99% of the cases if you're
like I'm I'm unsure whether a graph will
help me just just do one you know it's
not it's not gonna take that much time
okay Oh what is that yeah how did I find
this okay so mm-hm excuse me maximum
speed is a good question
I did I did sort of leave through that
so it's good to pull you back this is my
velocity function right I found that by
differentiating its for sine 40 so let's
call that let's just hijack this graph
over here even though it's very small
this is for sine 40 which makes its
amplitude 4 and its range negative 4 to
4 okay
so therefore the maximum speed is what's
the biggest that this gets like the
further this is away from V equals 0
the faster I am going okay so therefore
velocity for or voici negative for both
of them are a speed of 4 I should say
for what is centimeters per second okay
so that's where I got that from